oh crap hello everybody my name is
markiplier kind of forgot that that was
just about to happen right before I was
courting oh come on
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
deal with thumb seeing your dick bag
radical Larry first crap by running away
very far crap no no no there's good okay
so if i run away very fastly eventually
i get to the point where he won't be
able to keep up right right ah crap crap
wait a minute did i get away far enough
i don't know this is a hell of a way to
start an episode dudes huge sell what
I'm calling my fans out dudes so how are
you all doing today I'm doing great this
ah crap well I don't know what I'm gonna
do yep I kind of forgot where I was the
hell do I go we do hmm I don't know damn
it dead end
oh I remember this was a bunch of dead
ends and then I ran into uh the MTF
fourth or the nine tailed fox guys damn
it
dick bag dick bag ah
here we go okay so I'm not mistaken TF
should be right about right
now they're barely know here yeah I have
an idea
I have an idea oh oh he's gone now oh
really okay fine I need to go back and I
need to turn off the remote door control
that's something that I need to do I
need to do that that's very important
for multiple reasons for multiple
reasons hey look he left a piece of crap
on the ground alright so hopefully that
got rid of scp-173 up here cuz he was
gotta be in a tick
I did say Friday I saved a baguette did
I said the up here oh good he's not up
here is he am I sure he's nothing
you son of an ass bag hole how am I
supposed to be able to do this ah dammit
would you go go don't you be okay oh so
that's how it's gonna be a guy get that
switch oh okay
then turn no no leave it I need to leave
those on right cuz I know I need to come
back later and turn those on okay where
is he where si I don't I don't know
where he is I got it I'm gonna save and
go I think he's around this corner it's
not easy oh god oh god oh god ah ah
where is he I don't know where he is
guys I don't know where he is ooh I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know okay that's
weird
who
my mouse only does that twitchy thing in
this game I don't know what huh
there you are I lost my groom I didn't
watch my blink oh you son of a [ __ ]
oh here son of a [ __ ] why you gotta be
like that bro okay so he's down there
okay bling fur up high all right
whatever whatever whatever I'm just
gonna close this door on you under lock
and key and you can never ever leave
yeah all right oh hey hey hey
oh I have an idea I have an idea they're
coming up this way wait no behind me oh
no oh no I'm gonna leave them to deal
with scp-173 okay so this way hopefully
the MTF will
oh I see I know where this one leads
okay he's not down here at least I think
he's not
I hope oh oh I hate these little server
room doodads whatever they are oh
they're the worst I can't see a damn
thing
oh my god that was me okay all right
here we go here we go here we go okay
yeah yeah yeah this looped her back
around where I was just running away
from radical area if I didn't own that
it got back I would have I would come
sooner
MTF nine-tailed Fox
looky
okay all right
oh.he dokie where am I now
oh I'm in the cafeteria oh boy haha I
laughed at that before didn't I okay
anyway
alright so now I can uh I can get
whatever I need from this one ah ba ba
ba ba
uh uh what could I do with it I don't
know what could I do i I don't know I
really don't know see um I don't know if
there's anything that I actually need
aha
Oh out of range but he's right next door
don't tell me he's out of range how do i
how do i oh god how do I get out of it
again
how do I get out of it again huh how do
I get out of it again
I've forgotten do I actually need o
sight I need to actually dispense
something and then it gets out of it
right there was no cup down there was
there oh there was okay okay so I don't
know of anything that I actually need
from that so I'll just leave that be
Cuffy I don't need that and I definitely
don't need this so I'm gonna leave that
for now and then come back to it later
cuz once again I don't know what I do
with it
it's lovely that a place like this has a
cafeteria I mean I assume that it houses
all its workers on-site cuz they need to
be sworn to some sort of secrecy
ah crap I guess I know where I'm going
back into the pits of Tartarus otherwise
known as hell
please he's down here oh hi Billy didn't
know you come up these stairs that works
for me cuz I'm gonna go that oh crap oh
no no no which way do I go oh it's way
do I go
I'm going the wrong way
I'm going the wrong way oh god oh god I
can't see him where to go
stairs lovely stairs stairs beautiful
stairs wonderful l don't do that it
would be very bad to do the twitchy
thing right is 1 7 3 mr. Billy's coming
by okay here's a director's office I
don't know if they add anything
essential here listen make sure you
don't come up behind me let's relax a
little bit uh yeah there's a level fide
keycard but I don't need that anymore
see huh all right whatever I don't know
I got my little key I don't need the
card anymore what Oh close it okay all
right then
so I seem to be wait a minute wait a
minute how about been here before no I
haven't apparently oh I'm in the office
arian I'm in the office area now I
remember this ok so there's nothing
important here they segregated the
layout of the building so such that um
it made more sense logically than
completely randomized
all right so I'm getting closer to the
exit okay there's gate a right there
wait a minute do I want to go out gate a
I don't remember I don't think I do do I
I don't think I can no way I can that's
where the radical Airy thing that's not
where I want to go that I want to go out
Gabey
I saw a gate B before didn't I did I see
gate B already I don't remember
it's been a while oh good more radical
Airy poop what was that
what L is on ain't never seen no that
wide that open oh my god what happened
No I thought I heard radical Larry you
know what I'm gonna write let's stop
being pansy and go in hi ru oh I did it
oh I get it
Bert notes oh my god
stupid machine blah blah blah where did
the batteries go oh I can't
I'm beginning to think I shouldn't be in
here oh yeah get out get out get out get
out out conference room 9b what's in a
conference room is all-new ah okay well
this looks good have I been in here
before I don't know I don't think so
okay while we appreciate the concern and
obvious unease of you and your staff
there is a procedure in place for these
events the site must first be locked
down to prevent physical escape and
allow time to correctly assemble MTF
teams for evaluation and recovery any
subjects currently sealed on the site
are to remain there for the duration of
the breech event
nothing will be allowed to exit the site
until cleared by an MTF squad after a
full evaluation any subjects exiting the
facility will be considered lethally
contaminated and treated as such we
currently have a full evaluation and
review MTF team geared and to enter in
approximately one hour in addition all
outside communication needs to be
severed during a lockdown to prevent
mimetic contamination the fact that you
neglected to do so due to do so to send
the aforementioned message is unsettling
we will now manually sever all outside
communication links a disciplinary
hearing will be held for remaining
command members post evaluation and
recovery okay Trust is some backstory on
what happened to the poor sods that were
trapped in here with me I'm not locked
in with you you're locked in with all
the SUVs and I'm gonna cry like a baby
ah come on
that's bull honkey that means I gotta go
like all the way back Oh Alicia I got
some burnt notes what does it say I
can't get the section of recall set up
and brightest war he'sjust lair what
he's just lazy like a lion not sure what
why is there water gushing out of that
room seems I off I ship the old man
comes and takes me away off I run I give
it again sweet I don't know what this
guy is talking about I have no idea I
think he's a little crazy okay
damn it I don't know where else to go
was there another direction I could have
gone over here is that sound again
where does this go
what is that where's that lead oh wait
no that's directors off is okay I have
been here before that's right well where
did this one lead I don't know I
remember I go to so many all cases it
that's just yeah oh I wish I had more
sprint
oh well beggars can't be choosers
I've been hold off until next time okay
I'm gonna hold off all right so I'm all
I'm all that time for this one thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
at all so I'm definitely inside the mind
and this is taking a more literal sense
often grab a more than
it's actually inside the rain
that's what I'm pretty sure this
is about okay I'm going to go in here I
didn't look at the ceiling
see there
ha ha I'd be